hey guys my name is a cello and welcome
to the third episode of my flappy bird
series today will be initializing OpenGL
for the game and making sure the way
using the right verb inside our project
in the main class we create the display
as soon as that's done we need to set up
OpenGL there's quite a lot to set up in
the future but most of it can't be done
just yet since our game is only a few
lines of code right after we create the
display let's run a method called Anette
which sounds for initialize which we'll
use to initialize our game let's make
the init method just below start will
make it private since no other class
should access it the first thing we
should do is check that OpenGL was
successfully configured when we created
the display and the right version was
given to do that we'll need to call an
OpenGL method that resides in OpenGL 1.1
in l w GL all opengl methods and
constants are static which means we
don't need to create an object to use
opengl we simply call a static method or
constant since the method we want is an
OpenGL 1.1 the method is located in the
GL 1:1 class so we'll need to type in GL
one 1 GL get string and then GL 1 1 o GL
version this will request the GL version
string from OpenGL so let's set that to
a string of our own called version this
is fine but personally I hate seeing the
GL 1 1 everywhere especially since later
on we'll be using all sorts of OpenGL
versions prefixed to every piece of
OpenGL code will type fortunately
there's a way we can remove them let's
scroll up to the top where we imported
GL 1 1 instead of just importing it I'm
going to write import static which means
the Java will import a specific static
method that we want from that class now
at the end of the line we need to
specify which method or constant we want
to import I'm going to go ahead and type
in dot asterisks to import every static
method and constant there is in the GL
1:1 class then I'll move that line up to
the top to keep our imports more
organized by simply holding down the Alt
key and using the up arrow key now if we
scroll back down to our init method we
can remove the GL 1 ones from this line
there we go much cleaner let's go ahead
and print out the version to the console
and make sure it's the one we requested
now let's run again
as you can see in the console
running OpenGL 3.3 great that's exactly
what we wanted
if you see a version below that and
you've got the same context of trips
code that I have you've got a problem
please leave a comment below or make a
post to my forums of the channel comm so
I can help you out back in our net
method let's set the clear color to
white the clear color is the color that
our window will be cleared to every time
we decide to clear the screen we can set
it to white by typing in GL clear color
followed by 41.0 FS this will set the
clear color as RGB a red green blue
alpha to max which is white collar's and
OpenGL are generally expresses floats
and range from zero point zero to one
point zero the F's you see here might
look a bit foreign they simply mean that
the number we typed in is a flirt if we
leave out the f Java things the number
is a double and we can narrow by
appending an F beta lowercase or
uppercase to the end we're converting it
into a flirt now let's created render
method just below our run method inside
we'll simply clear our screen
particularly the color by calling GL
clear GL color buffer bit this should
clear our screen to the clear color we
set which is white
we'll call this random method every
frame so let's call it just above
display to update in our run method and
run again
great we've got a white screen opengl
3.3 is ready to use I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
don't forget to leave a like next
episode is going to be the brilliant
maths episode OpenGL requires us to use
a lot of vector and matrix maths which
we're going to write ourselves from
scratch get ready good bye